Cette année 2015 a été très très intense pour moi, et comme l'année dernière
je vais revenir sur ce que j'ai fait, faire le point
et comme ça ceux qui ne suivent pas n'auront plus d'excuses ! C'est parti.
L'année a commencé fort avec la sortie de mon premier court-métrage : Technophobe
Voilà. C'était la première fois pour moi que, je racontais une histoire plus longue
avec des personnages qui évoluent.
et l'accueil sur internet et par les médias a été exceptionnel
donc merci beaucoup d'avoir accueilli ça chaleureusement.
C'était beaucoup de travail mais ça vaut le coup
parce que c'était une histoire que je voulais vraiment raconter
et aussi prendre un petit peu de risques et montrer autre chose que des vidéos face cam. Une vraie petite fiction...
Ca m'a donné envie d'en faire plus
J'ai fait mon premier doublage au cinéma!
Ça c'est vraiment un truc que je voulais faire depuis que j'étais tout gamin, faire une voix...
Alors c'est une toute petite voix pour un tout petit rôle dans Bob l'éponge (c'est une mouette)
Mais c'était vraiment génial de donner vie à ces petits personnages
J'espère que c'est le début d'une longue série
Donnez moi n'importe quoi, une mouette, un caillou qui parle, je le fait!
Ça a été beaucoup demandé et j'ai publié mon "Draw My Life"
donc "Dessine ma vie", voilà où je raconte mon enfance,
d'où je viens, d'où viennent mes parents
Ça allie un petit peu mes 2 passions
C'est pour ça que je voulais faire ce "Draw My Life"
parce que j'adore le dessin, j'adore raconter ma vie également
Comme ça, je n'ai plus aucun secret pour personne!
"- Moi en 6ème" "-Je sais"
"Ah j'ai un truc entre les dents parce qu'à midi..."
"Je sais, je sais tout sur ta vie" *rire machiavélique*
Avec mes potes de YouTube, on a fait une vidéo sur Avengers
avec un budget exceptionnel de 27 centimes.
C'était vraiment fun de tout bricoler,
d'imaginer des plans avec pas grand chose, avec des plaques de plexi,
des costumes dégueulasses, des petits objets,...
Comme j'adore la Apple Watch d'ailleurs regardez la mienne comme elle est jolie
J'ai fait une vidéo pour la critiquer un petit peu. Désolé Apple,
Je ne voulais pas vous froisser, j'adore vos produits mais là vous avez un petit peu foiré quand même, on peut le dire!
Comme à chaque fois que je parle d'un produit, j'ai eu le droit dans les commentaires à:
"-C'est un placement de produit!"
"-Bah non puisque je critique le produit..."
"C'est un placement de produit!"
"-Non,non vraiment non... "
"-C'est un placement de produit!"
" -Je vais appeler un médecin quand même dans le doute... " "C'est un placement de produit"
"Je vais l'appeler tout de suite hein?"
Vous le savez, j'ai une marque de t-shirt qui s'appelle Narmol.
Cette année on était au Citadium à Paris,
donc dans un magasin, la marque était présente.
C'était super de vous présenter les produits, de vous montrer les dessins que j'ai fait,
de vous voir les essayer, d'entendre vos retours...
D'ailleurs la légende raconte que je porterais actuellement un t-shirt qui sortirait bientôt sur la boutique Narmol, voilà!
Pour fêter les 7millions d'abonnés sur Youtube, rien que ça, j'ai répondu à vos questions
et c'est là que j'ai découvert que François Hollande me suivait sur Twitter!
Je me suis pris un énorme vent, puisque 8mois plus tard je n'ai toujours pas de réponse du président à mon MP
(accent allemand) François, réponds moi s'il te plait
Si tu reviens, j'annule tout!
Pourquoi je parle comme un allemand?
Angela Merkel sort de ce corps!!
La sortie de mon 2ème court métrage qui s'appelle "Le hater" qui d'ailleurs est plus une sorte de sketch!
J'ai beaucoup aimé mettre en scène, parler aux comédiens, leur faire dire les répliques.
Je sais que c'était un peu osé de faire un truc plus court, dans un seul décor après "Technophobe"mais
c'était vraiment une histoire que je voulais raconter!
Cette petite bataille de regard, qui a mis ce commentaire haineux?
Tout le monde a joué vraiment bien: Justine, Nicolas, Catherine, Jimmy, Ludovic ...
Voilà, c'était des gens géniaux et également la grand-mère qu'il ne faut pas oublier!
Claudette, tu déchires!
Direction LA pour le salon du jeu vidéo!
Cette année j'étais accompagné du petit Lucas Hauchard, voilà qui a fait ses premiers pas à LA pour le salon du jeu vidéo.
C'était la 1ère fois pour lui, moi ça fait maintenant plusieurs années!
Et je vais y aller tous les ans, l'année prochaine aussi!
C'est vraiment une ambiance de fou parce que on peut voir plein de nouveautés,
rencontrer plein de gens, tester des jeux en avant 1ère.
J'aimerais tellement que vous soyez là,
vous mettre tous dans ma valise mais ça va coûter cher en supplément bagages...
On a fait une petite vidéo sur Batman avec Squeezie. J'incarne une sorte de Bruce Wayne pipo, Bruce Wayne pas cher qui avoue à ses potes
qu'il est Batman mais personne ne veut le croire...
Voilà c'était assez fou le tournage d'ailleurs
Le décor c'était un truc de malade, c'était un château qui a servi aussi pour le tournage du dernier Hunger Games!
J'ai regardé le film au cinéma, j'ai fait
"Mais je connais cet endroit, j'ai marché par là,
là où Jennifer Lawrence a marché!
Oh oui! Je me sens plus proche d'elle"
Et j'ai aussi porté un costume de Batman, qui m'a fait suer à peu près 10L d'eau,
et qui doit sentir un peu la mort à l'heure où je vous parle!
"L'école 2", premier tournage de la rentrée, c'était vraiment fun,
avec Jimmy Labeeu, Anthony Lastella.
J'aimerais bien sortir un bétisier de ce tournage parce qu'on a fait les cons tout le temps.
*crache* *rires*
*crache* "-Merci"
"Hum..."
"Non...Jimmy!"
Sur Cyprien Gaming on a eu l'immense privilège de recevoir
Shigeru Miyamoto (le créateur de Zelda, de Mario)
et Takashi Tezuka (le créateur de Yoshi et d'Animal Crossing)
Ce sont un peu les papas du jeu vidéo, on peut dire ça comme ça
et on leur a fait jouer à un niveau fourbe qu'on a créé avec Squeezie! Et on s'est bien marrés!
C'était super intimidant et en même temps une rencontre exceptionnelle...Voilà de Jouer avec les darons du jeu vidéo,
les piliers de ce que moi j'adore dans les jeux vidéos
C'était vraiment une rencontre exceptionnelle avec Shigeru Miyamoto parce que c'est un grand gamin!
Il a 63 ans mais il a une énergie de fou,
dès qu'il est arrivé il a touché tous les objets, il a regardé partout,
il s'est amusé avec n'importe quoi, a posé plein de questions,...
C'est un petit peu un modèle pour moi,
de créations, de ce qu'il a fait et aussi d'énergie.
"Abonnez-vous!"
On reste dans les jeux vidéos avec le Cyprien Gaming Show 2 ou plutôt le Squeezie Gaming Show!
On a crée une petite histoire un peu marrante où il me renverse, pour prendre les rênes de la chaîne Cyprien Gaming.
Avec ce spectacle vous avez très très très nombreux (encore plus que l'année dernière) à suivre le show
et ça nous a fait extrêmement plaisir, ça fait toujours bizarre de vous voir en vrai dans une salle,
ça nous touche énormément.
Et même en ligne (parce que oui c'était retransmis en ligne en direct sur Youtube gratuitement)
Et plus généralement sur la chaîne Cyprien Gaming on a vécu plein de super moments,
LA, le spectacle, mais aussi des lives, avec plein de stars qui sont passées, plein de jeux, et beaucoup d'amusement, des potos et tout ça...
L'année prochaine on va faire encore plein de choses.
En parlant de se rencontrer en vrai, on était à la Paris Games Week cette année, (l'année prochaine on sera aussi présents),
on était sur la scène de la coupe du monde du jeu vidéo.
Ça fait bizarre de jouer face à 5  000 personnes.
Ça fout un petit peu la pression et à chaque fois que j'ai la pression je perds!
J'ai perdu devant 5 000 personnes ça ma fait très plaisir!
J'adore ça moi! Ah ouais me faire humilier j'adore ça, l'humiliation...
J'étais présent à la Vidéo City Paris, c'est un peu le salon des YouTubeurs!
J'ai pu faire le con sur scène, faire des dédicaces avec vous, vous toucher un petit peu comme ça pour voir si vous êtes bien vrais.
J'ai aussi rencontré plein de créateurs du net donc c'était super intéressant de rencontrer d'autres Youtubeurs,
de discuter de comment on crée, de comment on peut collaborer aussi, il va y avoir des petites surprises!
J'y retourne l'année prochaine donc n'hésitez pas à venir ou à revenir
* cris du public*
Qui dit 8 millions d'abonnés dit vidéo spéciale et là j'ai testé des objets chelous que j'ai trouvé sur internet.
Comme par exemple un objet que j'ai oublié de déballer...
Un objet pour taper des mains...
Merci les japonais!
Ça fait 1 an et demi que je travaillais en presque secret sur ma BD "Roger et ses humains" qui est sortie.
Ça a été en rupture de stock très rapidement parce que vous êtes des fous, vous avez tout acheté.  Elle est de nouveau disponible.
Voilà, si vous voulez avoir un Petit Roger c'est possible désormais
Ça a été un peu de travail, on va pas se mentir,
beaucoup d'échange entre l'éditrice, le dessinateur, la coloriste pour enfin arriver à ça!
Si vous avez l'occasion de la lire, vous verrez qu'il y a un petit peu tout mon univers avec un petit peu d'humour!
Mais avec des nouveaux personnages qui sont assez étonnants j'espère!
Parce que je travaille déjà sur le tome 2. Ça veut dire beaucoup pour moi.
Quand j'étais gamin je pensais pas pouvoir sortir une BD un jour et en fait grâce à tout ce qui se passe dans ma vie,
grâce à vous, il y a plein de choses qui peuvent être possibles et du coup
le Cyprien qui a 8 ans il rêvait de trucs et le Cyprien qui en a 26 il les réalise.
Je suis parti à Londres 1 journée pour aller dans un cimetière pour le tournage du YouTube Rewind 2015.
C'est un peu la compil avec plein de YouTubeurs d'un petit peu partout dans le monde,
Sur un fond musical, pour faire une petite vidéo buzz réalisée par Youtube.
L'année dernière j'étais déjà présent dans le Youtube Rewind 2014 qui a fait quand même 100 millions de vues!
Je pense que j'y suis un peu pour quelque chose! Hein? Non? ... Ah ok
Comme chaque année YouTube a établi son classement des vidéos les plus vues en fonction des pays
Et dans la catégorie "clip non musical" c'est Technophobe qui arrive en premier
C'est vraiment mortel parce que c'est une vidéo qui compte beaucoup pour moi
et qu'elle soit la 1ère comme ça du classement, ça me touche beaucoup!
Et donc merci à vous les internautes, vous avez rendu ça possible donc ne changez rien! Si vous comptiez changer un truc, ne le faites pas!
On arrive à la fin de l'année 2015 et je viens tout juste de terminer le tournage de mon prochain court métrage.
C'est d'ailleurs pour ça que je porte un bonnet, parce que le personnage a une coupe de merdre
Voilà...
C'était 7 jours de tournage, c'était super intense, parfois c'était un peu galère mais la plupart du temps c'était vraiment fun.
On s'est vraiment amusés et moi j'ai adoré ce moment là
J'ai hâte de vous montrer ça, il y a encore beaucoup de boulot
parce que ça doit partir en montage, composition des musiques, mix son, étalonnage, effets spéciaux,
Ça sortira pas avant fin janvier, il y a encore beaucoup beaucoup de boulot et je vais m'y atteler de ce pas!
J'espère que ça va vous plaire. J'ai encore plein d'autres histoires
et pleins d'autres personnages à vous montrer dans d'autres vidéos donc...
restez pas loin sur Internet.
Et voilà, c'était les grands points de mon année 2015
Il y a encore plein d'autres trucs dont je vous ai pas parlé
mais à un moment il faut pas faire des vidéos de 3h.
Je pense que j'ai réalisé beaucoup de choses cette année.
Je pensais pas en faire autant.
Surtout que c'est des trucs qui sont très importants pour moi:
le doublage, une BD, les court-métrages,
et j'ai aussi pleins pleins d'autres surprises pour l'année prochaine Je vous réserve pleins de trucs!
Vous me permettez de faire des trucs encore plus ouf!
Donc merci beaucoup!
A l'année prochaine comme disent les vieux! *rire*
*musique*